suicide squad or even taking somebody
from the suicide squad and doing
something with them individually or
a couple of them or whatever i have all
sorts of
ideas and we talk about it all the time
so i don't feel like i'm done with this
villain verse yet you know there's no
one better in the world to direct
the suicide squad than james gunn
this movie was rad i loved it so much so
much fun
i i want to take it from the top of how
you went about
assembling your suicide squad because
there's so many characters to choose
from like
how did you pair them down uh you know i
just had to really kind of follow my
instinct but i did
start with a giant file of all of these
potential super villains that i found
from different places from
the dc wiki or you know comic book
characters i actually knew
or or whatever and then i made these
photo you know these copies what do you
call it when you print up something off
a printer
i don't even know what it's called i'll
say a photocopy a color
color copy of you know pictures of these
characters from the comics and i put
them all over my walls
and then started figuring out who fit
together because
i you know unlike a lot of groups where
you want everybody to kind of look like
they belong together this is almost
about making a group of disparate
individuals
who look like they didn't belong
together peacemaker looks like he's
from some crappy 1970s tv show and
rat catcher looks like she's out of a
saw movie and bloodsport is out of some
grim dark
you know thing and poking out man's out
of an alan moore
tale so they're all from these different
places and wanted to put them together
and have this very disparate team of
individuals
that all looked like they had had their
own history behind them
were you given any parameters of like
people you had to use or was there
anyone that you wanted to and you
weren't able to for whatever reason
nope no no no parameters at all i think
uh at the beginning
when i first talked to walt about doing
the movie
i said you know listen what's the deal
what do i have to do
is what do i have to keep from the first
movie and he said nothing
and i said do i have to keep that team
and he said nope
he said you can use none of them or all
of them he's like listen
we love margot and harley she's great
she'd be great if she was in the movie
but you don't have to use her you don't
have to use anybody
it could be a whole new team it could be
the same exact team it can be whatever
you want
and this is kind of where i ended up i
want to know what that conversation was
and like
because they're coming to you they're
saying hey we want to do a suicide squad
movie and you're like wait like
sequel reboot like what's right what's
the t so
what kind of conversations did you have
there and did you have any chance to
talk to like david ayer anybody about
those characters david and i didn't talk
until after
it was known that i was doing the movie
and then since then david and i have
talked a lot about different things
so when they first came to me it was
really it was about
what dc project i wanted to do and the
first thing they brought up was superman
and the second thing they brought up was
suicide squad so those were the first
two projects and then i had another
project
that they never brought up never thought
of a couple of other ones that we talked
about a little bit
people have talked about crypto they
know that that's a i brought that up at
one point
so there's different characters that
came up that interested me and i just
i just took some time and started
sketching out what
the different stories could be with
these different characters
and it was obvious from the very
beginning that suicide squad
just captured my imagination the most it
was the most fun
and people are like why didn't you do
superman or justice league or whatever
and i'm like
i just really found this to be the most
creatively fulfilling story and
you know i know someone's gonna do a
superman movie again
i don't know that polkadot man is ever
gonna get his story told
if i don't tell it so boy there you go
so i want you to tell his story i need
to tell rat catcher's story
you know and i've sort of made my career
off of telling the stories of the
characters that people don't think
they're going to have their
stories told but have something magical
to me about them at least
yeah that's the cool thing is i really
didn't know anything about guardians of
the galaxy and suicide squad i did but
like
not some of the more obscure ones that
you picked out here so this has been
really fun
to dive into absolutely great yeah so
how did you approach the idea of using
those same characters because
you kind of have to like break them down
and reassemble them
as new like what kind of conversations
did you have with joel and margo and jai
about hey this is
the same guy but not the same guy yeah
and biola i always remember viola
oh and of course viola yeah uh she's a
little meaner this time around i think
yes i think she you know really viola is
the antagonist
um she's pretty hardcore but if you talk
to viola how she looked at amanda waller
it's very much like
what she is like in this movie she's
pretty hardcore
and harley's pretty nuts and i you know
mario and i talked a lot about harley
and how i saw her and how she saw her i
actually saw
harley's a little bit sweeter in some
ways i think than she saw her
like a little bit more of a tenderness
to her that hasn't quite been
you know seen i think joel's changes the
most
you know rick flag is definitely
different in this movie
and that was a choice on the part of me
and on the choi
you know of on the part of joel to give
him
a little bit more humor give him a
little bit
more of a center you know i think at the
beginning of this movie
there are two characters that have
somewhat
compassion and and you know emotion
that's him and rat catcher
so i think that he really becomes in a
way a part of the heart of this film he
is
but he's also incredibly idealistic he
believes in what he's doing
he is you know america's hero
and being able to you know as he goes
through the movie sort of have
some of his ideals confronted in certain
ways and having to
deal with that so i think that he really
changed the most i think joel even uses
a little bit more
of the accent in this movie than he did
in the first movie you give everyone
like their individual like oh i really
want i'm really invested in rick flag
now i'm really invested in peacemaker
and of course you're doing
the peacemaker show i want to know what
what it was about peacemaker where you
were like oh there's a story here and i
want to do like an episodic thing with
him
well i think it's a number of things i
think that you know if you watch the
movie
obviously in the movie no some of the
characters happen
harley gets a really complete story
about herself she gets complete art
bloodsport gets a complete story rick
flag gets a complete story
wreck etcher two gets a complete story
like they all learn something about
themselves sometimes good things
sometimes
bad things but peacemaker
is a douche and he stays a douche and he
is
an [ __ ] in the movie but i think
there's something below that
and john and i talk to we see a lot in
flashbacks of
where ratcatcher came from and where
bloodsport came from
we don't get that with peacemaker and
john and i talked a lot about the
character where he is
how he feels how he is the one you know
you think that polkadot man's the one
who's the outsider but polkadot man
starts to feel
a part of the group peacemaker has a
harder time with that
he's actually the most disconnected of
all those characters
and seeing that john we scratch the
surface of john's
ability to act dramatically in this
movie
it's mostly you know comedy and silly
stuff
and i saw that ability in him and i
wanted to
explore that further and the comedic
stuff
and to give him a full forum and also i
think peacemaker has a lot to do with
where we are politically in this country
right now and that's part of what the
show is about we have
danielle brooks who's someone who in the
show is very very different from
peacemaker
and a lot of the shows about their
friendship or lack of a friendship
so there's a lot of things i think
peacemaker worked in to be a tv show
i saw you mentioned on i i think it was
a
what late show did you do the other day
kimmel
anthony anderson was there though um
yeah right you mentioned something like
oh we want to do another season is there
like a plan in place to do
multiple seasons of the show you know
there's not a big plan in place but
again it's something that i would i
would love to do and i know that the
cast would love to do so we're all
you know we haven't been picked up yet
so we'll just have to see what happens
from hbo maps
so of course you are the fabulous writer
director of guardians of the galaxy we
love those movies um
what would you say is the biggest
difference between approaching a marvel
project
versus a dc project i don't think
there's much difference i think that
it's really about guardians versus
suicide squad are very different you
know but i didn't go into
guardians making a marvel first movie
first and foremost i went into guardians
making
a james gunn movie first and foremost
and i went into suicide squad
not making a dc movie but making a james
gun movie first and foremost
they are first and foremost my movies
and they're the same in that way
however guardians of the galaxy is for
is it it has a family film element to it
so i'm telling that story to a lot of
different people
when rockets says to drax i'm gonna
shoot you in the face in the first movie
and kill you we don't as an audience
think in two seconds he's going to pull
out his gun and we're going to see
draxon's face disappear in this movie
the suicide squad they say they're going
to shoot each other in the face
and they don't only say it they actually
do it and we know it can
but even more so than them doing it or
not doing it we know that can happen at
any time
there is a much bigger sense of danger
for all of our characters in the suicide
squad
because we know all of them could die
whereas in guardians yes
i do kill i do you know obviously i
killed yondu and
that type of things happens i killed the
big original group
but it isn't the same thing we know most
of them are going to make it out alive
first two movies um
you know what's happening in guardians 3
you'll have to wait and see
can you could you ballpark do you have
any idea how many people die in
the suicide squad overall people
yeah i don't know but i think just in
the harley scene i think she kills like
42 people that we see
so that's in one that's in the one scene
so
there's a lot that scene is fantastic by
the way
um question those little cute
murder sea daddies what do we call them
i love them
cute murder oh the clyrox oh
clyron yeah
yeah yeah kinkshark's friends yes those
are some sort of
alien life that obviously they've picked
up somewhere that they're
been keeping alive in their aquarium so
you're gonna put me on a whole nother
thing because of course i have you know
my baby groove
my porgs and now clyrocks
now my clywrax clyrox yeah
um okay so real quick guardians three
coming up
everybody might die who knows um do you
do you see that as your
final like swan song guardians maybe
last marvel project
yeah wow but okay
you know the last marvel project who
knows but last it's it's uh
i see it as my last guardians movie i'm
a guy who never says never because i've
seen too many people say never and be
pulled back into the prey so exactly
that but i see it as being my last
guardians movie i know dave
sees it being his last guardians movie
and dave and i are pretty much attached
to the hip
on those projects so um i don't you know
i don't see
me going on and doing any more after
that yeah well they're exploring the
heck out of those tv shows i feel like
they're gonna float one to you at some
point
yeah it's just i'm doing peacemaker i
don't know
you know i direct five of the eight
episodes next season i hope direct all
all of the episodes so uh i
you know it is and and as you'll see
peacemaker is a very very different
show from anything that's ever been done
in the superhero realm
it is about a guy first and foremost
um and very very much secondarily a
superhero
but it's still a big science fiction
movie with tons and tons
more action scenes than any superhero
show ever so
it's uh it's really it's just totally
its own thing i'm excited do you think
we could get another suicide squad movie
yeah i think it's possible you know
suicide squad or even taking somebody
from the suicide squad and doing
something with them individually or
a couple of them or whatever i have all
sorts of
ideas and we talk about it all the time
so i don't feel like i'm done with this
villain verse yet you know
well i'm out of time but i i want to say
i've been interviewing you for like a
decade now
and this is my final interview i think
at et
so no it's coming but i i just want to
say this feels like a big full circle
moment for me
thanks ash it's been a play you know
that i think that you're always a
pleasure and it's the best and
you really are my favorite of everybody
so thank you thank you
i'll tell you what's going in the reel
next step soon i'll i'll see you soon
yeah i'll see you cut that was great
you